uh there are people gleefully cheering
that serial rapist and child sex
offender Larry Nasser has been stabbed
in prison now if you don't remember the
story I'm going to tell you about it and
I I do have a lot to say about the
reactions of some NBC news reports Larry
Nassar was stabbed multiple times at
Florida federal prison Union official
says Nassar was sentenced to decades in
prison for sexually assaulting gym
gymnasts including Olympic medalists
this this guy was the osteopathic
physician
who was just absolutely disgusting he's
referred to as a disgraced Sports Doctor
over many many years he sexually
assaulted uh numerous athletes that were
supposedly under his care although it
wasn't very caring what he did and in
fact he was convicted on endless counts
he was stabbed in federal prison 59
years old stabbed twice in the neck
twice in the back six times in the chest
sustained a collapsed lung reportedly he
is stable okay so listen there are tons
of people cheering about this and often
when sex offenders are hurt or raped or
assaulted in prison you see this
reaction oh this is great he's getting
what he deserves pedophiles don't get
treated very well in prison remember
Trump even joking about oh he's gonna
become someone's bride in prison or
something like that this is not the
progressive reaction and this is not me
saying oh I'm offended I'm offended that
somebody said that it's not about that
okay you can't complain about how
dysfunctional our prisons are and our
incarceration status quo is and then
rejoice in this and I'll tell you what I
mean I understand saying you know what
it's hard to find a lot of uh feeling
bad for Larry Nasser this guy is one of
the worst of the worst I don't feel bad
that this happened okay listen I'm not
asking you to go out of your way and cry
because Larry Nasser was stabbed and I
understand that what he did is
disgusting and in some sense you can say
well he deserves to suffer and the
suffering is that he's going to be in
prison likely for the rest of his life
but I urge you to reconsider
the gleeful reaction when convicted sex
offenders are attacked or assaulted in
prison no matter what our feelings are
about the offender and this guy is the
worst of the worst when we rejoice in
their being hurt in prison we are doing
something that is completely counter to
our views prison stabbings and rapes are
not part of the punishment prescribed by
the law and so therefore when someone is
sentenced to prison that's their
punishment they're sentenced to prison
and then they're stabbed or beaten up or
raped or whatever the case may be
it's evidence that our prisons are
failing our prisons are failing to keep
prisoners safe this is something bad
it's not something to be celebrated
because violence in prison isn't Justice
it's actually Injustice and if you look
at any other country where incarceration
rates and prison conditions make sense
to us as progressives
um prisoners are are safe it's a
violation of Human Rights it's a breach
of the rule of law and it's a threat to
Public Safety when the prisons are so
dysfunctional that people are attacked
and assaulted in this way violence in
prison is also not
um going to be part of the
rehabilitation that as progressives we
say listen we we want there to be an
aspect of Rehabilitation in prison now I
am not naive and believe everybody can
be rehabilitated I don't believe that
but certainly violence in prison and
prison rape aren't even plausibly part
of that Rehabilitation and also when we
cheer for prison violence we're
essentially endorsing a culture of
brutality revenge and vigilantism that
is not only dehumanizing again it's
against what we say we want our prison
system to be so I would encourage
everybody who has been happy about this
and there have been many to think about
it a different way we should be outraged
not about Larry Nassar specifically but
about the fact that our prisons lack
total human dignity and they lack human
rights and much the same way that I'm
against the death penalty not because I
think serial murderers are great people
who should have fun lives going to
baseball games okay but because when we
support the death penalty
we are supporting killing by the state
and I don't support that we're
supporting Revenge by the state and I
don't support that so it's not about
Larry Nasser it's about as progressives
we want at minimum adequate security and
health care and proper nutrition in
prison okay and then we can talk about
education counseling actual
Rehabilitation Etc
um let's not be happy about this it's
just weird when I see supposed
progressives happy about this and uh it
is you know Larry Nasser should get to
miserably serve out a sentence in a box
for the things that he did
but he should not be stabbed that's
evidence of the failings of our prison
system if you disagree with me let me
know and make sure you're subscribed on
YouTube youtube.com the davidpackman
show and make sure you're following me
on threads I'm on threads at
david.pakman quick break back after this